today I have good news for Malta in our
view Malta has made enough progress
implementing its National recovering
resilience plan
to get a first payment under Next
Generation EU so as soon as member
States agree to Malta will receive over
50 million euros
let me give you some examples
Malta has stepped up mapping investments
in industrial Innovation that's so
important
or there are improvements in the field
of Waste Management notably in the
construction sector that's so important
for our circular economy
and we recognize the reforms put forward
to strengthen the fight against
corruption
and the increase of the independence of
the Judiciary
all this is just the beginning
Malta is set to receive nearly 260
million euros to roll out reforms
and to get Investments so keep up the
good work Malta